well hi jenna hey how are you
it's good to see you over zoom how does
it feel to be
on the set of screen 5 right now
it's crazy it's weird too because when i
first
started i've always said i've always
wanted to do horror so
this is a huge dream come true like i
i don't even think there are words in
the english language to
correctly express how happy
and excited and nervous i am for this
journey and
um it's just it's so amazing to me
what can you tell me about your
character if anything
you're gonna get me in trouble i don't
know i think
here's the thing too everything is super
top secret so even on set
interacting with other people uh it's
it's very peculiar because you'll start
talking about something and then you cut
yourself off because wait
do you have the same information that i
have oh wow
yeah there's bits and pieces that are up
in the air for some people
and i never want to be but what i will
say is
having seen all of the previous films i
am
very very pleased with
how the script has been written and
everything that's to come
scary night isn't it with the murders
and all it's like
right out of a horror movie or something
are there a lot of callbacks to the
first four like can you
does it feel like it fits with the
franchise does it feel different
it fits perfectly and then also how
incredible that we have the main cast
coming
back that is insane to me especially
because i mean
how many years it's been like nine
almost 10 years since
screen four which is insane to me but i
mean
even that i mean i i feel like
throughout the years
the the french press has done really
well at calling back and bringing some
sort of
nostalgic aspects to the to the script
and
i'll i'll definitely say that there are
some here have you met
courtney david nev yet no i haven't met
them yet we're in
pre-production right now so we're still
getting you know the wardrobe and
meeting with hair and makeup
and and um things like that so i've only
met
a few of the cast members also i don't
know if everybody's here
yet there is a rumor that selena gomez
is in the movie
do you know anything about that i wish
as an actor
they would tell me things but like
honestly i am the last person to ask for
information like that i haven't even
that i'm like
at this point do i even know everything
that's happening for you
i mean you just did the babysitter
killer queen
i think snakes are the most
misunderstood reptiles
my favorite movie vacillates between
deliverance or
anything by rob reiner and i'm late
obviously you now spring five
what does it feel like to sort of become
this scream
queen in a way like is that something
that you ever set out to do is it just
kind of a natural thing
how oh i never look at myself as
a scream queen no i feel like that's
just sort of been a natural progression
i think horror is just so fun to make
it's also very easy
to make in hollywood or you know
whatever yeah
in the industry uh so it's it's just
something that's kind of happened
how has it been getting back to work
with
all these new policies and precautions
in place it definitely feels
post-apocalyptic
you know it's just a weird weird
environment especially as someone who
likes to engage with all of the cast and
crew
and introduce myself and you know i
wanted to be a comfortable
environment for everyone so i've done
every test under the sun i'm pretty sure
in terms of you know the picking of the
fingers the spitting in the cup the no
swap but i've done it all
every other day for months but also it's
a
it's definitely a wary environment you
have to be conscious of how other people
may be feeling you know
some people are more sensitive to the
subject others are not
i think it's important that uh you know
we we all just listen to each other
i do want to quickly talk about you
season three
has that started in production yet have
you shot it yet uh they haven't started
yet
one covid has kind of put a
halt or postponed a lot of productions
but also
i believe that penn penn is going to
become a father so i think that they
also are allowing him some time to um
spend some time with his child which i
think is
very very um sweet so i
i'm not really sure what's happening
with that and then even like the way
they
they ended the second season it's very
who knows
it's kind of up in the air with ellie my
character what would you like to see for
ellie
if she i feel like she could be the one
to expose joe
i would love that for her i do want her
to at least be able to hold something
over joe's head which i think she
she's able to do even with just her
presence but even you know how there's
constant
pressure being added to joe and you know
qualms that
that are kind of thrown at him
throughout throughout the season
so i just would love ellie to come back
and be one of those well let's talk
about this new series it's called
jurassic world
camp cretaceous
it was such a fun animated series to
watch
for you what was it like to sort of
immerse yourself
in the jurassic world of it all but
animation style animation it's a
completely different world than live
action
while you're still active and in in the
scene you
almost have to exaggerate it a little
bit more because you know it needs to
carry throughout your voice
i had an incredible amount of fun
i i heard that some of the audio that
you guys reported was actually done
over zoom during this pandemic
so how did that all work out it's hard
because
you know sometimes we do ensemble
sessions where the entire
cast was on and someone would drop out
if you're doing
adr and you need to see the scene so
that you could sink your lips oh now
it's lagging
you know so it i i definitely think it
was harder and it's so much nicer being
in a studio
but i'm so glad that we were still able
and fortunate enough
to get some stuff done were you a fan
of all the original jurassic park movies
yes yes it's so weird everything about
this project has been so
hush-hush so i don't know what i can and
can't say and it's
uneasy ground but even recently i found
out about our producers and amblin being
involved and things like that so it's
all just very
you didn't know that spielberg was
involved not initially
no no i found themselves like a month
ago because i found an
article and i said wait
oh my god i was stuck
completely in the dark that's crazy well
they probably had to keep it hush-hush
for good reason
you play brooklyn and she's kind of this
pink-haired influencer type of character
what was that like for you to sort of
tap into
i feel like i have a lot of experience
in terms of dealing with press and promo
so i understand
brooklyn's um side of things in terms of
always promoting herself
but i think brooklyn and i have a lot of
differences influencers make such an
impact on our generation now
i don't want to make her too mean or too
cocky or narcissistic but also there are
some qualities that
just naturally come but i also find that
she's a very insecure person and
i think i think she has more depth than
people realize so i'm excited for people
to kind of
discover that you've been very busy
during this time i think you've already
shot
two movies during this pandemic one was
demi moore one was jen
garner is that right jen garner was
actually
like a few weeks before everything shut
down
i did the demi moore um song bird
which that was the beginning of
quarantine it was actually the first
production back
in l.a super thrilling to be a part of
um
and it's such a interesting set
how has it been to sort of see the level
of your career kind of explode over i
feel like the past year or two
i i feel myself slowly becoming the
person that i think i want to become so
to be able to work on these projects
that are not only exciting to me but i
you know could um create or manifest
excitement for other people
is super pleasing to me i mean for me
it's just
i love what i do i really do and i've
been wanting to do it since i was six
years old and i didn't get to do it
until i was around 10 so i feel like
every job i'm just it's such a blessing
and i'm so grateful
you